(percussion music)
(audience applauding)
- I mean, first of all,
I wanna jack your outfit.
That's so cool.
I like your dress.
- Of course, you can have it.
- It's so cute.
- I didn't know it was sparkly
until it came in the mail
and I was like,
"Oh, okay."
- Surprise!
- That's like perfect for stage, I know.
That's like the stuff I look for
whenever I perform or whatever,
'cause it catches the
light, it's really pretty.
(Taylor chuckling)
You have the same name.
I know this is old news to y'all,
but it's so funny to me.
Is it hard, when people are...
Does it ever get confusing
with emails or questions or?
- Yeah, what's the most difficult part?
- The mail.
- Mail.
- Yeah.
- Mail, probably.
- "Oh, this is yours.
No, it's yours."
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like this holiday
season's gonna be tough.
There's gonna be some
gifts ruined, for sure.
(Kelly chuckling)
(audience chuckling)
- Opening up of the wrong,
that's amazing.
- Yeah.
TSA, check-ins at the
airport, they get very-
- They're like, "We need Taylor."
And we're like,
- "It's both of us."
- "Which one?"
- "Hi."
- "Yes.
Hello, we are both."
- They're like, "No, Taylor Lautner,"
and we're like,
"also, both of us."
- Oh my gosh!
It's just kind of incredible
that you found each other.
(Taylor chuckling)
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- I don't know one person named
Taylor in my personal life.
The fact that there's, yeah.
- Okay.
- Yeah!
- Well now you got two.
- It's not as popular,
I don't think, to me,
so now I'm like, "Yeah."
So wait, so your first
anniversary is coming up, right?
- It is.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, are y'all doing
something fun, first one?
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] What are y'all doing?
- Yeah, we're actually
doing a fundraising gala
for our nonprofit, for our anniversary.
- Oh, well that's awesome.
- Yeah, we're super excited about it.
- Did you purposely do something not
for you, but for others?
- I mean, yeah.
- We've been waiting
to do our first gala
or fundraising evening
for the non-profit, and it just felt right
when we were talking about what we wanted
to do for the anniversary,
we were like, "Should we go
somewhere, blah, blah, blah,
but like, or we could," you know.
- We love sentimental things,
so it just felt right
to do it then.
- I think it's beautiful.
I think it's a beautiful thing
to do on your anniversary.